this is the smallest and cutest little
action camera ever the new insta360 go
3. over the last two years this has been
one of my favorite little cameras but
there's been like small things with each
generation that I'm like man I really
wish they would do this or I wish they
would do that and now with this version
they've actually added some surprises
that I didn't even know that I wanted
let's check it out so we've got a couple
of things to unbox here we've got the
actual camera itself we've got a little
monkey tail mount a quick release Mount
and a mini two-in-one tripod I love how
many different accessories that they
have this makes it so much more fun and
versatile when you're out filming and
shooting you just got all the right
little things that you might need
look at it it is so tiny it is still
magnetic but it's also got these little
quick release sides on it so it'll
actually attach to the mounts so it's
way more secure which is definitely a
problem that I had in the past the
magnet is pretty strong but if you're
doing you know Action Sports and you're
really getting into the action you
really do want this to be attached okay
we've got our camera got our user guide
which actually I know I always like
throw out directions but I'm gonna I'm
gonna set this aside because this may be
useful
ah and we've got all of our mounts here
I love the smell of new technology my
goodness that smells delicious so this
is so awesome this basically will turn
this into like a traditional kind of
action camera but what's really awesome
about it it will be able to wirelessly
transmit the video to the screen so I
can have this off to the side I could be
filming and somebody else could be kind
of monitoring it okay let's keep that in
there get that all charged up we've got
some mouse in here so this is like your
traditional kind of tripod mounts this
is the little quick release
oh that's also magnetic look at that
it's magnetic but to release it you do
have to push those little buttons on the
side I also really like this Mount
because this will give you all sorts of
different angles look at that so good
and the bottom of this is a little
sticky Mount so I'm not going to take it
off now but this is cool because this
will let you kind of attach this to
anything really it does say to please
make sure the surface is clean before
applying sticky pad and there's a little
cover for it too
this is the little hat clip so this you
would clip to your hats
it's really in there that's great
like you have to push this little button
here to unlock it
so it's not going to fall out or
anything so this is a little hat mount
this is magnetic this doesn't have any
extra little clasps in it but for the
most part this has been so fun to test
out I loved putting this on my hat while
I was out in Hawaii doing hikes this
though is one of my favorite accessories
it's a magnetic necklace Mount and they
added this in so that you can wrap the
cable up inside of it it was just so
nice because this little cord would
always get stuck in things whenever I
would have it in my travel bag so now
this just will completely fold itself up
inside or you can unravel it
feels
stronger than the other one
that's very strong here we go this is
how I like to wear it
so cool this right here is also pretty
cool this is a new addition to the Gen
3. this is a little wedge that you can
attach to the necklace and this will let
you get a different angle because before
when you have this attached you would
only be getting a straight view but now
this will allow you to get like a
downward Angle an upward angle and you
can change the view slightly with the
little wedge nice little addition oh my
goodness so many things and we're not
even done yet
we've got the mini two-in-one tripod
a little tiny
oh that extends actually more than I
thought it would cute we've got a nice
little quick release Mount I have
shredded this box absolutely shredding
it this is why I'm excited because this
has a built-in little tripod mount so
you'll be able to quickly attach this
little mount to the bottom or even to
your action camera and this will give
you quick access to be able to mount it
or even attach it to just a regular
traditional tripod
detail Mount I've actually never used
one use one of her but it looks cool
this is probably heavier than everything
that I just unboxed in this entire thing
this is cool like I could wrap this
around my arm
it's even thinking like an easy top-down
camera definitely gonna be trying this
out let's take a closer look at this
little camera I'm obsessed with this
little enclosure like they made it so
much more useful because now not only
will this charge it but you can use it
as a separate viewer so I guess let's
turn this on and get it set up here's
how we switch between shooting modes and
if I slide the edge of the screen I can
get my settings this is great because
before you really couldn't see what you
were filming
I'm recording oh my gosh this is my
first video hello hello hi peace
um and love peace and love okay bye
so here it is this is the smallest and
cutest little action camera ever it is
so lightweight and it has this
incredible magnetic mounting system that
lets you attach it to all sorts of
accessories this lets you get all sorts
of shots that you'd never be able to get
with anything else it shoots at 2.7 K it
has up to 173 minutes of battery life
with this new action pod it has the ever
so popular Flow State stabilization to
keep everything looking super smooth 360
Horizon lock the camera is waterproof up
to five meters it's got voice control
and AI editing there's a lot of fun
modes that you can shoot in like time
shift slow motion time lapse time to
capture and pure shot HDR photo there's
three different versions that you can
purchase depending upon the capacity of
storage on the camera I'm out of my
first test with the insta360 go three
I'm excited I'm just gonna sort of take
some photos and some videos and see how
it works on my walk slash run we'll see
if I get to the running but I gotta do
it for the testing I've got my hat Mount
I've also got the neckline this Mount so
I'm excited to try that out this is
something that I used so much on hikes
on my previous version when I'd be
climbing rocks and doing things that I
had to be hands-free it's the necklace
chest mount
hello little donkey hi honey hello sorry
I don't have any snacks for you look at
that look at you you're so cool
okay bye
[Music]
okay I just found a hole and this is a
huge hole look at this
I'm gonna put you guys in there
what do you guys see
you guys see anything I mean this is
real like right in the middle
is somebody gonna fix this
I don't think they are we have got hat
mode engaged now I feel like this might
be the mode that I use more often kind
of being able to see in front of me and
then when I look down I can see my feet
the other frame that I tried out was
flipping it super close to my face so it
basically was just like this is what it
looked like I feel like the train guy on
Tick Tock if you've ever seen him he's
always like running to get to the trains
and he's always so happy huge fan
um I'm not sure if this is a mode that I
would like and there's also another when
I well I guess it depends on my outfit
I need a t-shirt for this one now the
other cool thing is this can actually be
used as remote control so I can remote
view what this is seeing so if I do have
this on my head and I want to make sure
that it's framed upright or I want to
switch to photo mode I can do all of
those things right here and it makes it
super simple
things that I like is if you don't want
to bring this case around you don't have
to you can just bring the little tiny
side camera okay
and added
to give you extended battery life and a
viewer so you don't have to have it but
it is nice to have it turned it into
like a traditional action camera
this is a nice day out
I'm not gonna do anything to you
[Applause]
oh don't be scared so it's time to keep
testing now in those previous shots I
was filming in a set standard mode but
now I'm gonna use freeform and I love
this because this allows me to really
get a lot more flexibility with my
footage so I can go into the insta360
studio app and I can choose however I
want this to be framed I also really
like this because this really does take
advantage of the full State
stabilization and you'll see here while
I'm out riding around in this how stable
this footage is it's gonna be so fun so
let's rig this up and head on out
[Music]
now I've got this set up where I have
the monitor right here so I can actually
see what I'm filming I can hit record I
can change some settings so let's go for
a ride and get some shots
[Music]
foreign
this is the last shot of the day so
let's hope I don't run it over like
actually run it over
foreign
filming is finished the best part is
editing I love that I'm able to use
insta360 cameras so seamlessly with
their mobile app it's awesome because
you can basically import all of the
footage you can edit export and save
everything right out from your phone and
then post it they also have some
incredible AI editing which I'm not
gonna lie I love to edit but having AI
do it for me and add a soundtrack and
text and everything this is awesome to
be able to get out content super quick
doing things on mobile is so easy on the
go but if you do want to export in
higher quality that's when you can use
the insta360 studio app on your computer
so I can change this from Ultra wide or
if I want it to be linear depending upon
what look I'm going for I can change
these clips and then export them all
directly to my computer and take them
into Final Cut to edit or Premiere or
DaVinci whatever it is that you edit
with thank you guys so much for watching
I had so much fun testing out this new
insta 360 go 3. this was so much fun and
I cannot wait to take this on some more
Adventures it's it's gonna be so
incredible I love the previous versions
and now this one is better than ever if
you guys haven't already please
subscribe and hit the Bell to be
notified when I post new videos and if
you want to check out any more of my
videos they will be here on the end
screen and with that I will see you guys
in the next one see ya